let's go next to our caller from the
nine one eight area code I want to go to
nine one eight caller from nine one
eight if you can hear me by all means
introduce yourself
yeah I've been calling from Oklahoma
alright Ben what's going on um my
question is I'm wanting to know your
favorite US president and why uh man I
feel like I am just way too cynical to
even answer a question like that I I
don't have favorite presidents or
politicians I don't know like who if I
really thought about it who would it be
I guess Margaret Thatcher would be my
favorite US president I don't know no
I'm kidding um I I have no idea I don't
know how I would possibly answer that
like do you have a favorite president
pain go with Teddy Roosevelt he was a
badass
real rough rider you know the National
Park seemed credit to him
not to say he doesn't have you know Kahn
walked in his path of course yeah my
favorite president yeah I just I met
you've stumped me completely been I
don't know however ham Lincoln's a safe
choice maybe that's the thing it's
always lazy today some people go with
the recency and they're like Bush Bush
was the real great Republican or Reagan
is a popular whiner
some progressives like to say Obama or
Clinton and then the classics are like
Washington and Lincoln and then there's
baby or JFK crowd oh yeah I have K as
well I don't know do you have a favorite
president Ben mm-hmm it's kind of hard
to know especially from like the one
they're like a long time ago but I guess
if I had to pick one and probably be FDR
FDR that's actually maybe FDR's by I
think I might take that Ben may be FDR's
my favors I hold Japanese internment
thing the Japanese internment thing is
dicey and hurtin horn yeah but the New
Deal and you know real stimulus and
dealing with World War two there's a lot
there actually ii billa right
right yeah yeah all right Ben I'll think
about it more and then I'll try to get
back to you with a more specific answer
surprised you didn't go with like
Zachary Taylor William Henry Harrison
Millard Fillmore I found Taft
interesting because he had to have
custom extra big bathtubs made for him
in the White House and just from like an
interesting architectural standpoint and
sort of like engineering that's
interesting he golfed almost as much as
Trump does
is that true I don't know your big
golfer RI Ben thank you interesting
question which I had a better answer for
you go do thank you all right no problem
and on that note let's take a break we
will pick up a few more phone calls
after this